because people will disappoint you your
church WIll disappoint you your your
spouse will disappointed your kids will
disappoint you everybody will disappoint
you
and then you'll find out that you'll
disappoint yourself
so what are you gonna do right you could
just live in that despair or you can die
right you can choose to die
and if you choose to die then then
there's a surprise
right there's actually a surprise which
is you could call it the resurrection a
little one little Resurrection is that
all of a sudden some of those things
start to shine be Fuller than what you
thought when you were trying to hold on
to them
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
I love not talking first
because because every time I get all
these ideas that are different from what
I was going to say in the first place
because the fall was just bringing us at
all these powerful images
um so first of all it's great to be back
with some of you and to meet some of you
all these faces a lot of people that
I've been you know even met them on
YouTube or been met them on Zoom calls
and all of that so it's just wonderful
to see people in real life
uh and thanks for thanks for coming so
I'm gonna give the most anti-symbolic
talk that I've ever given I think
it's what I'm gonna do today uh
you know when the title
when the title came the Quest for a
spiritual home
the the image that right away came up
for me was that that's uh it's
impossible right there's there's an
impossibility in the finding of a
spiritual home uh and uh I don't know
why that's the first image that came to
me
uh but I came to formulate it this way
maybe it's gonna actually be a bit of a
technical question that is that that in
order for the world to exist we cannot
own a home
that's maybe one of the best ways to
formulate that and there seems to be
something in the way that
we formulate our stories the way that
the big story is formulated the one that
Paul brought us on you know from the
fall to the eschaton that is captured in
the Christian story that seems to be um
hinting
at this all the way through
um
so what is
why do I say it's going to be an
anti-symbolic talk it's that I the most
of the time what I tend to do is to
point people to the beauty right to the
fullness to the fact that the world is
full of light that the world is full of
the grace of God that the world is full
of these patterns that that point us to
their meaning and our and shine uh and I
think that that's absolutely true but
there's also another aspect to the way
the world exists which is that
we always have to be disappointed in the
things that we find along the way and
that's actually that's actually a
necessity
it actually has to be that way there's
no way around it
and it actually and it has to be that
way
for the you know when I talk about this
hierarchy of
of reality right these layers of how the
world exists as this fractal structure
of things embedded into each other well
it seems like one of the corollaries to
that or one of the things that makes
that possible is that everything
while being full
is also always insufficient all the time
it always has to be
and that seems to be a big part of the
story that you find in scripture like
the whole big narrative and the
crucifixion is the surprising
uh part of that it's one of the most
surprising ways that the story tries to
deal with that that problem
so we see it right away in the beginning
in the story of the garden which is that
God places Adam and Eve in this
beautiful space and Paul is absolutely
right that it is definitely related to
the temple or we could say I like to see
it the other way around honestly I like
to see it that the temple all the
imagery of the Temple
that we find in scripture the Tabernacle
uh you know even ezekiel's kind of
prophetic Temple is a memory
say call it a memory of the garden
that we are made in a way
that we have a nostalgia in us we're
built with this nostalgia
we have a sense in which
we should find
something like that we we want it we
desire it we we're looking for it in
everything and when we hear the story of
the garden you know it's a uh it's a
it's a mythological
description
we recognize in that story something
which is true not only in a in a kind of
historical like let's say
historical way where we have this idea
that there were people that lived in a
garden before but that it is in some
ways the the structure of our our
everyday experience right we know the
when we engage in something when we see
it shine and we move towards it is
because we see it as a
as a breadcrumb
leading towards Paradise because uh if
we try to find rest in any of those
breadcrumbs
right right away
we realize that it's not enough
that that that breadcrumb is not enough
and the story of Ulysses uh that Paul
had brought up this morning I hadn't
thought about that as an example but
it's a it's a very powerful example
where you know Ulysses has this massive
Adventure trying to find to go back to
his image of paradise to his garden to
his wife uh you know even the imagery in
the the the text is very similar by the
way to Genesis because his bed is made
out of a you know it's like it's like
it's like embedded into the a tree that
was planted there and it's like it's
like embedded into to his own his bed is
like built out of a tree that is there
and so it really is this powerful image
of this Central tree right this tree
that we see in the Garden of Eden and
his wife as the his home as the space in
which he finds rest
and it's powerful it's the perfect
imagery it's a perfect imagery you know
when Paul brought up the image of the
Heavenly Jerusalem that is how
home is described that is how the
Heavenly Jerusalem is described as a
bridal chamber as the place where you
know the man and the woman uh meet where
they find rest in each other you know
where they find we could call it
productive rest where life is born all
of that it's it's it's exactly what that
is
but it is uh
it's something like an eschatological
memory
we can put it in the past we can put it
back in the mythical times we can put it
back before the flood in history or we
can project it into the future uh as the
ultimate goal as the ultimate
destination but that's how
it appears necessarily
because in some ways it sustains
uh
it sustains the world when that image
lands
uh when it happens
there's an aspect of it which is bright
and there's an aspect of it which is
death
that's how we encounter it we encounter
it as a coming into something real
and then ultimately having to give that
up
and if we don't then it becomes a
becomes an idol right that's the whole
story of idolatry in in scripture is has
something
to do with that all these things that
are good we try to grasp them
then they immediately uh
they die you know they they so we we
have to give them up on purpose we have
to let's say let them die willfully so
that we're not caught with this Frozen
dead thing in our hand and right that's
right there in the in the story of
Genesis that's what happens you know
there are many Traditions which say that
the the fruit that God had forbidden
Adam and Eve was going to be given to
them it's there in Jewish tradition we
find it in the church fathers you know
you've heard me if you've listened to
any of my videos you've heard me talk
about saying that from the Syrian Senate
from the Syrian says that explicitly
but in order for it to be real they
couldn't grab it for themselves
it was the grabbing for themselves that
transformed it into death
that God was to give it to them they had
to receive it as a as a gift from Heaven
is the best way to to describe that
um
so I want to give a
you know I always give the same examples
but you can kind of understand it in
anything that you experience and when I
say that this is true for the world to
exist
I really mean it technically I mean it
in any anything that you can imagine
anything that you can participate in
it always has to give itself
towards a higher participation always
right walking you always you're when
you're walking you're walking for a
purpose and that whatever that purpose
is it's somehow embedded in another one
and another one and another one and
there's a sense in which if you're
properly aligned
then all of that gets filled with with
light you know if you if you work and
you make money that's great if you try
to grasp it and you do just that for its
own sake then all of a sudden it becomes
becomes idle and that's true about
anything it's true about anything that
is even religious
and that's why it's so difficult because
people think that you know and I'm
Orthodox I really believe that like I
believe that icons are holy I believe
that you know I believe in the
sacraments I believe in all of that to
be absolutely real
but there's a way in which we always
always have to be careful and understand
that this always has to be a breadcrumb
towards more because if we think that
we're going to find our spiritual home
in this world we are you're going to be
disappointed if you think you're going
to find
a rest like a kind of rest where you can
just kind of stop
uh yeah you're going to be very
disappointed and that's and I say that
it's important because you know in some
ways I'm telling people go to church
right I say it all the time you know if
you go to church you should go to church
I'm just you know you should participate
you should participate but it's
important to understand that you will be
disappointed
yeah you're gonna run up right up
against the wall you're gonna go like
Orthodox people Catholic people you're
one day you're going to go to confession
and you're going to say it you're going
to talk to the priest and the priest is
going to say something absolutely crazy
to you like completely insane you're
like you're gonna go you're gonna go to
church and you're gonna find out that
you know oh this guy's cheating on his
wife and this and that all of that is
gonna happen to you there's no way
around it you will be severely
disappointed
in the world but like I said there's a
manner in which that has to be true
right I'm not making excuses for anybody
right Christ has a great uh saying one
of my favorite sayings of Christ which
is that uh Scandal must happen
right but woe to those by who's it ha by
who it happens
right horrible things are disappointment
breakdown people not living up to what
they should is absolutely necessary
it doesn't excuse their behavior it
doesn't excuse what they're doing but is
absolutely necessary so that you are
able to to not
hold on to it that you're able to let go
of it as a as an idol or as something
that you think is going to bring you
ultimate satisfaction
and so we live in that tension
always that strange tension and once you
understand that tension it can help you
uh actually understand many of the
images and of the way that the Bible
talks about
all of these questions because in the in
the story of the Bible and also in the
story of Christ you will see that
tension always played out
and it happens like I said right away
in the story of Genesis Adam and Eve
grab the tree
and because of that they lose
their home they try to grab it they lose
it
and then Cain after he kills his brother
tries to build a home and it's like a
it's like a weird Scandal right he's
like he's trying to make a home for
himself and
you know is that good is that bad should
we do that should we build try to build
homes should we try to construct them is
that our job is that our role and the
answer is yes and no it's it's both it's
both at the same time
uh and so we see an image of Cain
building
that civilizational thing building that
City leads to the flood we see an image
of that in Babylon as well and in Bible
you really see what the what the image
is in some ways Babel is the opposite of
the Heavenly Jerusalem
if you want to have a good image of how
that functions you see that in the story
in Babel humans try to make a name for
themselves you can understand that
exactly as this taking the Apple for
oneself they tried to name it's great
because we actually in a time in the
world where everybody is trying to name
themselves they're trying to self name
they're trying to grab on to even hold
on to themselves as their identity as
being full as being full
uh and because of that they they
necessarily lose it there's no way
around that and like I said it's a
technical it's a technical thing anytime
anything you're doing that has multiple
parts of it
anything if you're driving a car
and all of a sudden you just get really
hypnotized by the turn single signal and
you just like get you I don't know
you're obsessed with the turn signal
you're gonna crash your car
right anything that you do that you try
to grab on to the parts of it
it will collapse the the whole thing
that's that that's how it is and so the
Tower of Babel shows you that it's a
powerful image because it tries to take
one human name one human identity and
raise it up into heaven and make it the
home for all right make it the universal
home for everyone we're gonna solve
everyone's problems we're going to
create a system that's perfect we're
gonna we're gonna settle this
you know and that that doesn't work and
the Heavenly Jerusalem is is exactly the
opposite that it's a beautiful image of
this
fractality and it actually it actually
helps you see how it is possible to have
homes how how can we live it how can we
find consolation in the things that we
participate in without uh
without
making them into little tyrannies and
the image of the Heavenly Jerusalem is
first of all at the center of the of the
city is is the garden but also the lamb
we'll get to that why the lamb is at the
middle there but you it says that the
Kings and the Nations give up their
Glory bring their Glory into the city
and that's like that's exactly that's an
image that's the one of the most
powerful images of reality I think that
has been described is that in order in
order for us to be able to find joy and
some consolation in the world we have to
always be giving it up towards a higher
participation and as soon as we try to
grab it as soon as we try to rest in it
then it becomes then it breaks down
there's no way around it and that is the
the best image of civilization that's it
that's the best image of civilization
you've got is the idea that we all have
our identities we all have our families
we all have our Nations our languages
you know the things that we care about
and the only way for those to hold
together is for them to always be kind
of given up and and offered up
and that's why in some ways there it's
always a dime
there's always an aspect of reality
which is something like willful
dying
you know doing dying on purpose
so that you're not surprised by death
giving up some of that control so that
you're not surprised when the ground
Falls from under your feet uh
foreign
so in scripture you'll see that
the homes and the rituals and the Kings
and all the structures are often
represented as concessions
God is conceding this stuff to humans
it says if God is saying I'm your home
you know but God is in heaven like you
can't live in heaven I mean
and so but he's like this is where you
you know you I'm trying to bring you up
the mountain right I'm trying to make
you come like all the way to the top
where you will come into contact with
the infinite where you will find you
know joy in the highest good but you
know God knows that that's not going to
happen and so God is always kind of
giving concessions
and that's why it's represented that way
and sometimes it can be a little
alarming because you know even if you
read the book of Exodus you'll see it's
it's kind of always God is always kind
of conceding
you know that God tries to give the law
himself you know writes it on the tablet
with his own finger ah that doesn't land
it's too high
so God's like okay Moses you you right
you write the law rights you do it and
so now Moses writes the law and then
that us it's lower and it kind of lands
but then you know okay so Moses is Moses
says I need help I need help so you know
God adds Aaron and then adds all these
all these other other things and you I
had this weird sense like it's a
concession and you see the same in the
story of king of the king you know
everybody loves to point out
that the king is a concession in uh in
scripture you know the people ask for a
king and then God uh tells the you know
Samuel tells the people that if you have
a king the king is going to take things
he's gonna he's gonna act like a raptor
right you're gonna have something above
you like a almost like a like a raptor
Bird that's gonna come and take things
from you uh and he's totally right but
then weirdly there's another image in
the Bible in the Book of Judges
especially
where everything's really chaotic and it
says the reason why it's chaotic is
because there was no king in Israel so
you think how do we have those two
things together how can we have on the
one hand all of civilization everything
that makes us human be a kind of
concession and something that in some
ways
isn't good enough
but at the same time it becomes an
actual image of the way that God reveals
himself into the world
ah and I think that that like I told you
that in some ways that tension between
those two sides that's actually the key
to understanding how the world works and
in some ways that's the key to living
your life
you kind of always have to navigate
between those two things you know it's
like you fall in love with someone and
and you know it's it's amazing and that
person is your home and you you're like
this is it I found it you know and then
you
then you get married and then you
realize that was not the case
like that this person is not gonna
fulfill all your desires not going to
fulfill all your aspirations just not
it's just not going to happen and I'm
sorry if there's anybody who still who's
in a new relationship and thinks that
that's gonna happen it's just not gonna
happen I don't know what to tell you uh
uh so get ready for that but but that's
that's the the thing is that once you
realize that that's actually how the
world works then then maybe it's not
that big a deal and actually not only
it's not that big a deal but in some
ways maybe that's actually the path
towards your own betterment it's
actually the path towards your own
salvation is that finding the places
where reality disappoints you
is an opportunity to
make that next jump
uh you know I I heard uh through through
a friend of mine who was a nun
she was saying that her Abyss she she
would always say that you know that the
heart breaks make the best nuns like
those women that were heartbroken make
the best nuns
because in that disappointment right in
trying to find satisfaction in a man to
find their home in a man in that break
uh it became an opportunity for them to
move
further to move up from that
um
and so I'm saying that obviously it's
it's hard it's impossible right it's
really impossible to do that but in some
ways it's the only way
to do it there's no other way because
life will disappoint you
because people will disappoint you your
church WIll disappoint you your your
spouse will disappointed your kids will
disappoint you everybody will disappoint
you
and then you'll find out that you'll
disappoint yourself
so what are you gonna do right so so you
could just live in that despair
or you can die
right you can choose to die and if you
choose to die then then there's a
surprise
right there's actually a surprise which
is you could call it the resurrection
a little one little Resurrection is that
all of a sudden some of those things
start to take to shine and they actually
start to be Fuller than what you thought
when you were trying to hold on to them
right it was it was Chesterton that said
uh
that before he was a he was a Christian
he would chase after liquor and cigars
and women and then when he he became a
Christian he realized that he could
finally enjoy
cigars alcohol and and a woman but it's
because he wasn't running after it
anymore like he wasn't that wasn't his
purpose he had turned his eyes towards
something higher and then all of a
sudden the simple the joys of the world
became consolations when they were there
but they weren't that which we expected
of reality we didn't expect it we don't
think that it was owed to us like I'm
owed this I'm owed this this home if I
can't find it I'm going to live in like
bitter disappointment for the rest of my
life
and this is it's important for us to see
it especially today because
you know we have a consumer culture
obviously and we're promised
that all these things are going to bring
us satisfaction and some of us we think
we think that we're not materialists and
we're not affected by that but the same
problem happens in the in the church in
the churches or in our spiritual
communities is that you know there's a
reason why the the modern world has so
much hopping you know from church to
church or from this to that is because
in some ways we're looking for the
perfect home I'm not saying you should
just settle for anything obviously I
made that move you know I moved from one
Camp to the other and I I joined the the
Orthodox tradition
um
and then I was severely disappointed
right and then I was disappointed
luckily there's like you know it's funny
the reality is made in a beautiful way
like God is made in a beautiful way and
that's also why we fall in love I think
is it's good that at first we're kind of
drawn and we we don't see the Death part
of it we just see the light and it's
great because it it's it's like it is
like that crumb that brings you closer
um so it's good that at first usually
when people join a church or the you
know they they they they convert or they
get baptized you know for the first six
months depending on people it's like
right it's like uh it's like they're in
heaven for a few months a year it
depends on people uh you know uh and
then it just like then it then all of a
sudden you you see that no this is not
your home you know this is not your home
uh and that's I think helps us
understand uh the image of Christ more
fully
why did Jesus appear the way that he
does
um
and there's a way in which the idea that
the lamb is at the center of the holy
city
it's very powerful
this idea that the Lamb of God
which was sacrificed before the
foundation of the world that's a very
powerful image
because we tend to have an idea that
death and sacrifice
is it that's the concession you could
say or that that's like the the the
exception that Christ came to die
because of our sins and that's why
the cross appears but there's a very
deep deep mystery
in the notion that that's actually how
the world is made
and that at the highest point and at the
top of the hill is a sacrifice
and that in order to have the world
exist
it has to be given up you have to give
it up
and that's actually how everything else
falls into place once you give it up
then you get it back you know and the
story of the sacrifice of Isaac that's
exactly what that is
you know that's exactly what that is God
says
you know God doesn't say it that way
but ultimately it seems that God is
saying for you to have your son you have
to give him up and if you don't you
can't
you won't have him
and that's actually the only way and you
could think about that in all your
relationships you know everything all
your relationships if you think about it
that way
that
you know if you love your wife you have
to be willing to give her up
if you love your children have to be
willing to give them up
and that once that happens then you stop
grasping so you don't grasp so much
and then you find these surprises right
these beautiful joyful surprises that
come that come with that gesture
um
and so that's when we come to the image
of the of the crucifixion
there's a
in the in the Orthodox tradition we have
it's one of my favorite I maybe is my
favorite service in uh in in the church
here
it's a service of lamentation that comes
on Holy Friday
and it's a it's a kind of a meditation
and a lamentation of Christ who is on
the cross
and the imagery that is used there is
the is the craziest imagery like it's
some of the most powerful imagery
and what happens in that poetry is a
collapse of
home and death
together
right where the tomb of Christ is the
bridal chamber
you know where the the man who is dead
on the cross is the bridegroom
um
that the
that Christ entering into the tomb that
is the highest Sabbath
that is the highest rest
and like that clash in your mind right
it's hard to hold it together
but you know I hope the way that I've
tried to kind of set up that tension for
you to understand that in some ways
that's actually how how uh reality works
and when we say you know when I say that
it's hard to explain it but when I talk
about Christ and I and I tell and I tell
people like Christ is revealing
the way reality works it's not just it's
not just a story you have to believe in
to be saved it's actually showing us the
way that the world is made and I think
that in the image of the crucifixion
obviously with Resurrection coming
without the resurrection then yeah then
you're right then it's just some guy
dying it's just some just death but the
idea that it's think about the sacrifice
of Isaac in the image of the crucifixion
that's what's going on the same thing
but now it's a self like now it's
self-sacrifice now it's a Christ who
gives himself up
Christ who gives himself completely was
willing to die who's willing to let go
to let go of everything the surprise
behind that
is that that's what makes you exist
and that's what makes
the fullness of your life possible is in
that spot and you give up
and so then you can understand all the
right all this idea that in some ways
the imagery of us being strangers in a
Strange Land the imagery of us not
having a home the imagery of the
ascetics for example think of all the
monks that go out into the desert and
are you know that that want to give
everything up it's not a
it's not just a kind of masochism right
it's not just a kind of of uh it is
looking for fullness but knowing that
fullness comes through sacrifice now
we're all we're not all called to do
that obviously I'm not a monk uh but
those images and especially the I mean
especially the image of the crucifixion
uh they become
a marker
of how reality works and that
the reality in which we can exist you
could say that and so I'm not called to
sacrifice myself fully
I'm not necessarily called to go live in
the desert but you know
I'm I maybe I'll sacrifice you know I
won't work 15 hours a day and I'll spend
some time with my kids maybe I won't you
know I won't buy that new car or
whatever and you know I'll give that
money to the church or to charity or
I'll you know I I will understand that
it's actually giving up
things
that those very things find their find
their real their reality I always
there there's a there's like a there's
like a little secret joke behind all of
that right there's a funny secret joke
behind all of that which is that
let me put it this way who enjoys food
more
a billionaire at a banquet
right or a monk eating a piece of bread
that hasn't eaten in three days
who do you think has more pleasure
it's kind of weird huh
and then you realize that it's not and
the thing is that I'm almost like I feel
I'm almost probably shouldn't even tell
you that like I shouldn't say that
because I the idea is not to fast so
that you have more pleasure you know
like that like like some of the like
some of the the
um epicureans but that is gonna happen
actually it's like uh you know and we
see that in the the way that the
Orthodox tradition presents the
spiritual life that's actually how the
whole spiritual life is presented I
often uh bewilder people when I tell
them that if you read the writings of
the monks and the ascetics they tell you
to not care for any spiritual experience
like don't but his Visions don't don't
pay attention to that consolations
forget it don't think about any of that
it's like you you see an angel you see
Christ or the you know appear to you
ignore it
it's like what especially like in this
modern like kind of psychedelic type
people world where they all want to look
looking for Spiritual experiences and
you think no that's actually how it
works
that's actually how it works and so the
monk that ignores the spiritual
constellations in a strange
contradictory in a strange Paradox will
have more spiritual consolation than
anybody who like is gonna go out to look
for their little spiritual experience
and that's actually that's actually like
I said how the world Works
um
and so ultimately I think that you know
hopefully you'll see that it it is
anti-symbolic in the sense that
it's the type it's the aspect of reality
that I that I don't talk about as much
but it's very important uh it's very
important and it's true for all the
things that I say that the secret part
of it or the the hidden part of it is
that all of the things that I talk about
all of the beautiful imagery all of the
powerful manifestations of these
patterns they all only exist in uh in a
in a sacrifice they'll only exist in the
manner in which they're capable of
emptying themselves
into higher higher participations and so
we we have to not we have to enjoy
the meaning that is provided to us by
kind of seeing the world that way but we
always have to be careful not to
not to grasp it so
that was our message for you this
morning
[Applause]